[Music]
even though gravity falls has some of
the biggest hiatuses we have ever seen
we really appreciate this hilarious show
if you have to admit that some episodes
were so scary and inappropriate they
definitely weren't meant for kids
wait until you see which episode makes
adults shut their eyes because it's so
scary give this video a thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe to our Channel
let's check out 10 gravity falls
episodes that weren't for kids the
inconveniences alright let's start with
something light the inconveniencing
immediately starts with dipper asking
Mabel if she believes in ghosts and her
replying that she believes he's a big
dork charming isn't it it's definitely
something kids shouldn't say we have a
feeling parents also wouldn't like the
fact that Wendy didn't listen to her
boss and invited Mabel and dipper to the
roof of the shop
even though Sue's told her not to the
kids are seen throwing pinecones from
the roof and when dipper hits a car he
sets off the alarm
but even though dipper scared Wendy's
totally cool about it she even
high-fives him something tells us that
parents wouldn't be amused if any of
their kids pick up these habits because
of gravity falls and of course Wendy
also skips work and disappears to hang
out with her friends one gray and work
ethic then dipper realizes he's having a
crush on Wendy when she asks and how old
he is he says he's 13 which is a
complete lie all that just to see some
kids shoot beans at someone's belly we
all know kids always want to hang out
with the cool teenagers but this episode
makes it very clear that kids should
never do things like riding on a car or
hang out at a haunted convenience store
talking about giving in to peer pressure
carpet diem this episode is not so much
a bad life lesson as it is simply just
one of the weirdest episodes ever carpet
diem is the 16th episode of season one
and it starts with Maybelle playing her
own version of mini golf we don't have
to say that you definitely shouldn't
play mini golf like that inside your
house right when dipper finds out that
maybe I was having a sleepover he
totally freaks out because obviously he
has to share the room with them we also
learned that Suze enjoys hurting
and although that's not too much of a
surprise kids shouldn't try doing the
exact same things after the sleepover is
over Mabel and dipper fight and realize
they want to have their own room just
like that sis finds a mystery shack in
the Attic when dipper and Mabel stand on
the shaggy blue carpets they end up
fighting and magically swap bodies talk
about being creepy this is exactly like
Freaky Friday but possibly scarier
watching Mabel and dipper freak out is
actually quite scary this episode is
actually so complicated most kids would
never get it the worst part of this
episode is definitely grunkle Stan
explaining the birds and the bees to
dipper this episode has a lot going on
and none of it is meant for kids
scary-oke scary-oke has a completely
different setting than some of the other
episodes this one is one of those that
is beloved by adults more than it is by
kids it all stars with Stan working on
the universe portal and the announcement
that the government agents will travel
to gravity falls Stan obviously doesn't
like the fact that the government is
visiting mystery shack
dipper tries to convince the agents that
the leprechauns journal is actually
valuable to their investigation of
course they don't take it seriously when
they see what kind of things are inside
but pay attention as the agent opens up
a page and shows it to dipper you can
see two cryptograms
one says watch out and the other
translates into kill me please pretty
gruesome for a kids show right
it gets even scarier when dipper
continues to convince the agents that
the journal is real and zombies start
coming out from the ground at this point
the episode becomes much darker and
intense we have a feeling there are a
lot of kids out there that would have
nightmares from these zombies it gets
even scarier when soos turns into a
zombie and asks kids if he can eat their
brains although it all into the karaoke
session we have a feeling many kids we'd
want to skip the second half of this
episode into the bunker and to the
bunker is the second episode of season 2
and although it's the seventh on our
list many fans seem to think that this
episode features one of the scariest
monsters of all time we've already
talked about zombies but some things as
scary as the gravity falls
shape-shifting monster first you have to
get through dippers awkward crush on
Wendy but that gets better after a while
the scary parts start when the gang
almost gets squashed in a room Wendy and
dipper get trapped with the shapeshifter
monster after being tricked he's the
author of the
after they tried to run away and escape
with the journal they get chased and
honestly it's pretty scary if you think
about it this monster could transform
into practically anybody
Wendy even gets a bloody knee from
trying to escape the scary
shape-shifting monster fans admit that
the shapeshifter is one of the scariest
gravity falls characters ever we
definitely agree
it's especially scary to see Wendy
turned into a shape-shifter and dipper
struggling to tell which one is the real
Wendy as sue says good luck sleeping
tonight if you're watching this episode
although the cutest part was definitely
dipper admitting to Wendy's that he
likes her talk about ending the episode
on an adorable note however wendy is
Right dipper is definitely too young for
her not what he seems
Maybelle admitting that she's a creep in
this episode is pretty hilarious the
kids and grunkle Stan decide to light
some fireworks on the roof and although
it seems Stan has something to say he
actually supports this decision and even
encourages Mabel to set something on
fire we have a feeling parents wouldn't
want their kids to do this without their
permission or a permit according to
blubs whether Bluffs has a permit for
being totally lame is also probably not
something you'd want to hear kids say
especially to an authority but Stan
getting tackled an agent suddenly
securing the house and arresting him is
definitely scary especially when the
agents claim that Stan is definitely not
innocent in this whole situation
Stan and Maybelle then find some fake
IDs and an article that's probably mind
blowing for many adults they reveal that
Stan Pines is actually dead and that
there's a grifter at large who looks
exactly like him it's pretty creepy
seeing them figure out who they've been
actually living with this is definitely
an episode that's meant for adults the
secrets the mysterious codes and some
sense of humor thrown in the mix will be
appreciated by adults more than kids of
course you also finally meet the author
of the journals which is completely
mind-blowing the tooth
welcome to the dipper's guide to the
unexplained the tooth is an animated
short that should be avoided by anyone
who doesn't like to see well teeth or
weird puppets but we'll get into that
later dipper is trying to find out what
would the random big tooth close to the
lake the tooth is gigantic and bigger
than any fish dippers ever seen
hey Mabel investigates a lake but what's
even scarier than being at the lake
during the night is Mabel's childhood
bear bear Oh even dipper admits he's
creepy and his face is definitely not
the kindest tell so pretty weird hearing
Mabel do the deep bear voice even the
cartoon kids hate bear
the bear and Maybelle doing the promo
for it through the entire short doesn't
make it any better
of course this short gets even weirder
when Mabel and dipper row their boat and
end up getting attacked by a giant head
the scenes move far too fast
and quite honestly they're definitely
not meant for kids even though this shot
is only a couple of minutes long Barrow
made it seem like it's even longer
everyone's afraid of Barrow which is why
this is definitely one of those episodes
that shouldn't be seen by kids or adults
who are afraid of puppet bears roadside
attraction first lesson of roadside
attraction is don't actually spray the
bug spray on hitchhikers we're telling
you Stan isn't exactly a good role model
for kids we also get another glimpse
into dippers obsession with Wendy sure
being in love with someone is one thing
but having that many photos of her seems
a bit weird doesn't it roadside
attraction also features one of the most
terrifying characters on the show that
gave everyone nightmares including
adults and no it's not that cringey part
where dipper gets practically asked on a
date or dipper getting pretty much
mobbed by all the girls that came on the
trip it's a completely different
character
remember the spider lady it's exactly
why we think this episode definitely
isn't meant for kids
Darleen is pretty creepy but so is Dan
and Darlene flirting after Stan takes
Darlene on his so-called date he ends up
stuck in a spiderweb and what's more
scary than a regular spider a blond
headed woman with big earrings and
spider legs it gets even worse when she
takes off her human mask and turns into
an actual spider and it's not just kids
who should stay away from this episode
roadside attraction should be avoided by
anyone who suffers from arachnophobia
Darlene is definitely not the one you
should be messing with the hand that
rocks the Mabel the hand that rocks the
Mabel is easily considered to be one of
the worst gravity falls episodes but
even a bad episode like this has it's
good moment however there's a character
in this episode that might even be
creepy for adults let alone kids lil
Gideon is one of those characters that
makes every single episode creepy he
might be little but he stands mortal
enemy he's manipulative and frequently
uses mind control and telekinesis even
on Mabel his crush we're pretty sure he
even makes a couple of adults totally
uncomfortable we do have to say that his
dressing room is completely fantastic
even though his pickup lines are
incredibly lame dipper makes a good
point never trust anyone whose hair is
bigger than their head low Gideon is
definitely one of those people that
was a bit over the line and basically
makes everyone uncomfortable including
the people who are watching this show
he's also rude and extremely
inappropriate to the restaurant staff
and we can imagine no parent would want
their child to put their feet on the
table like that we're also not really
digging the Gideon and Mabel
relationship the two don't even have a
cute chip name not to mention he peer
pressured Mabel to say yes to him to
another this relationship is definitely
not something for kids
the last Mabel corn the last Mabel corn
starts off pretty scary especially since
we get to see bill cipher once again you
have to admit his voice is pretty creepy
and that whole scene at the beginning
seems a bit out of ordinary even for
gravity falls it seems like these that
could easily give kids nightmares this
episode isn't actually that bad apart
from the fact that we learn about yet
another one of Stan's crimes
dipper also gets an important lesson in
trusting people but first it's time we
talk about pug trafficking some ongoing
joke and gravity falls only it's really
not funny kids might think these pugs
are cute and it's adorable to see a few
barrels of pugs in the back of
Santiago's van but it's definitely not
cute when you hear that Stan is actually
trafficking these pugs across the border
which is most definitely illegal kids
don't get any ideas we've said it before
that Stan isn't exactly a good role
model but the scene in the last Mabel
corn reminds us that the team beyond
gravity falls is able to get away with
pretty gruesome ideas those poor pugs
wait until you see about the very last
episode that was probably the scariest
of them all it wasn't for kids but some
adults have reported they were pretty
uncomfortable watching it to Northwest
mansion mystery
welcome to the scariest episode of
gravity falls the Northwest mansion
mystery has been noted as the episode
that will definitely give kids
nightmares which is exactly why it's on
our list sure it gives us a new insight
into Pacifica and dippers relationship
which was never really that great but
there are definitely a few scenes that
shouldn't be seen by kids who want to
sleep peacefully it all starts when the
Northwest manors
starts to levitate Pacifica asks zipper
for help and of course Mabel once dipper
to help so she can go to the mansion
party and that's what the problem start
from the strange painting to the talking
animal has with blood coming out of
their eyes this episode is definitely
much scarier than any other gravity
falls episode you have seen and it gets
a hundred times worse when dipper and
Pacifica wake up the coast of the
Northwest mansion and he rises up in the
fireplace scary music a big ghost with
an accident agenda and creepy ghost
noises are really what makes the
Northwest mansion mystery one of the
scariest episodes ever what's the
scariest episode of gravity falls you've
ever seen make sure you let us know in
the comments below that's it for our
video for more videos like this one
check out 10 cartoon secrets finally
revealed see you next time
[Music]